i'm michael knowles filling in you can
find me on apple podcasts at the michael
knowles show you can find me on twitter
at michael j knowles and very often
when i am filling in on this show you
can find
madeleine kearns who is a staff writer
at national review focuses
on this crazy gender ideology that seems
to have
taken over the country even though as a
medical matter it affects like four
people but for some reason as a
political and cultural matter
it has taken over everybody there is a
story that came out
this week halle berry a wonderful
actress
very talented has won many awards halle
was being considered for the role
of a transgender man which
for those who are not familiar with the
lingo means a woman
who dresses up like a man and identifies
as a man
and she is pulled out of that because
apparently today
an actress is no longer allowed to play
another woman who is playing a man
because of political correctness or
something i don't know joining us now
maddie kearns maddie thank you so much
for being here thanks for having me
so i i don't even know where to begin
with this
there are so many levels here and i know
you you are a trained singer a trained
performer so
i think you might have a little insight
on the showbiz aspect too
let's let's start with that am i
mistaken or
uh are aren't actresses supposed to
pretend to be other people isn't that
the job that's generally how it has
worked for a very long time yeah and
actually of course cross-dressing in
theater has been the thing for a very
long time
as well the thing that halle berry did
is she made two
cardinal mistakes the first thing she
did was that she
had the audacity to say that she was
going to play
a role which she hadn't had the lived
experience of that role as a transgender
person
which is obviously on its face
preposterous and then the second thing
she did was that she misgendered this
fictional character
can you believe that she misgendered a
fictional character
by referring to this uh transgender man
as a woman
and she said this was a woman's
experience in a woman's story
i think that was actually her attempt to
say actually i might not have
everything in common with this fictional
character but we do have that in common
which makes sense because normally
casting decisions are made
based on some kind of common thing that
you might have
in order to bring to that character so
yeah so she made two big mistakes there
obviously those are very big mistakes i
suppose in this woke culture though it
would make sense to me i mean just even
as a purely casting matter if you're
trying to cast
the role of a woman who dresses like a
man
you you would cast a woman for that
because women who dress like men tend to
look more like women you know at least
in their
physical structure i'm also reminded of
one of the great acting theorists in
america stella adler trained so many of
the great
film stars of the 20th century she had
this joke where she said
unless you happen to be danish royalty
then you're going to need to use your
imagination to play hamlet you're going
to need to
pretend but but now i don't know it
seems like the line is being blurred
between what is real and what is pretend
we're being told that pretend things are
real and real things are pretend
there was a similar incident that
happened last summer with scarlett
johansson
where she initially she initially stood
up for herself and made the point that
well i'm an actress
i can play a tree if i want i can play a
badger
if i want she obviously is very
confident in her acting abilities i
think i would personally struggle to
play a tree i don't know about you
michael i know you're
a trained actor yourself it's very
difficult but you know one can build up
the inner life and you have to work on
the sap and those sort of things but
that's all beside the point
yeah i just think it's obviously
difficult to to really do
that wrong justice because it is an
innominate uh you know
a piece of vegetation but in any case
she did make the point that this is
exactly what you're saying this is
supposed to be using your imagination
to get across empathy uh to tell a story
really and it is a fictional story so um
so yeah it's a bit ridiculous
it is and i don't know where this goes
because
you know for so long we've heard that
women are
not treated well in hollywood obviously
the whole metoo movement was about
how men dominate hollywood and women
don't
don't have any power or any real sway
jennifer lawrence was complaining about
this
everybody was complaining about this and
then it seems to have shifted on a dime
back to giving all the power back to
biological
males is that are we not going to expect
some kind of
feminist response to this i mean where
where's where's halle berry's uh
solidarity with the sisterhood well
unfortunately she just caved right away
and and started speaking as somebody who
had been recently re-educated she said
i now understand my cisgender probably
you see that i sort of glaze over when
you start to hear that language
but um but yeah it's it is really
strange how there's not so much feminist
backlash as you would expect
i also can't help but notice a double
standard in 2015 i think it was eddie
redmayne played the danish girl
and he was not only able to play that
role that is the role of a transgender
woman
he was uh nominated for an oscar right
so
there just seemed to be a bit of a
double standard here why is it actresses
that can't play trans characters
but uh actors can one of the people
who's in the culture i think we spoke
about her last time
was jk rowling and she she gets a lot of
flack from the woke
intersectional left because she is not
down with transgender ideology she's
more of an old-school feminist she wants
to defend
women's place in art and culture and
politics and jk rowling just signed on
to this letter
there were a lot of people think about
150 people signed on to it's being
called
the letter in harper's and it was this
letter of of
mostly liberal people i mean some even
as far left as noam chomsky
saying that we need to stop canceling
people we need to stop removing them
from the culture
because they contradict whatever the the
leftist orthodoxy of the day happens to
be
and first of all a couple of people have
already pulled out they've retracted
their signatures i mean it's getting a
lot of attention
because it's being viewed as a betrayal
of the left where does it stand
do you you know it seems to me that
there are three groups here there are
the conservatives
and there are the woke crazy leftists
and then there are like five
old school liberals in the middle trying
trying to maintain some order and
and civil discussion is that a lost
cause
where do we stand on on the kind of
consensus that seems to have evaporated
it is a lost cause insofar as the woke
the locust of the walk are not actually
interested in compromise
so even if you say i'm happy to use the
preferred pronouns that you wish i'm
happy to accommodate
trans people and so far as it's
reasonable which i think most people
including conservatives are fine to do
that you know the key part that sentence
being insofar as it is reasonable
i.e not sports teams um it doesn't
matter because unless you're a hundred
percent with the agenda
then you will be canceled what was funny
about that letter though michael was
i read through it a couple of times and
i was struck with how
liberal the language and the terminology
was they had reference to equality
inclusion there was lots of dunking on
the radical right
all these things there's a lot of
dunking on trump there's a lot of
dumping on trump
trump exactly and yet this is not good
enough so this is i think you just can't
really compromise with these people and
so
obviously in our particular career
choices we've just decided
not to care and say what we like and
there's their freedom that comes with
that
although i don't think we're ever going
to work for the new york times i hope i
hate to break it too
i hope we're never going to work for the
new york times i'd be so ashamed if if
we were
i think you're right though i think
there is this kind of balkanization
happening
and there there are some people i notice
that especially on like the
the center right or there are people who
really want to just
get along and compromise and meet in the
middle and it just
strikes me especially on this
transgender issue
there's no middle what's the middle
either a man can become a woman or a man
cannot become a woman and if a man can't
become a woman
that has certain public policy
implications and men cannot be permitted
to go into the girls changing room and
and you know go on from there and if a
man can become a woman
then that also has public policy
implications and that man has every
right to go into the girls changing room
and that man has every right
to go into some sports team and win the
track race
and that man has every right to take
women's parts in hollywood
where can the compromise be well this is
exactly right and this is actually why
you find that these old school liberals
that you're describing are very much
in an uncomfortable alignment
uncomfortable from their perspective
with conservatives like like you and i
because
really we are actually saying the same
things now i think perhaps you and i
might be
slightly more blunt about what we're
seeing uh but but we are seeing the same
thing which
which is no i'm sorry we really do have
to draw the line somewhere
and typically we draw the line at women
and especially
children yeah but this is this is never
going to be enough it's just
you know that you're just going to find
yourself being cancelled so
yeah that's the way it is yes there's
there's no way to appease the mob
it reminds me of that old quote that you
know you you feed the crocodile hoping
that he'll eat you last but he will eat
you eventually
it seems like everything's heating up
into 2020. it's i
maybe call me a crazy wild conjecturer
but it seems to me
that a lot of what we're seeing in this
country and the riots and the statue
toppling and
the intensity of public debate might
have something to do with this
presidential election that we've got
coming up in a few months
i remember in 2016 when this transgender
issue came up
president trump took a different tact
than most of his
fellow republicans who were who were
talking about the kind of philosophical
basis of this
why from an anthropological perspective
it's just not not possible that men can
be women all this
trump kind of dismissed it they said do
you think based on these north carolina
bathroom laws do you think men should be
able to use the women's room
and his answer was i don't know what
were they doing before what were they
doing before this became a big issue
that seems like it's fine i never heard
of a problem let it go
do you think he'll take a similar
approach here you know he leaned away
from that transgender issue in 2016. do
you think it will play a role in the
election
as the as the workstars have gained so
much ground
or is the election going to be more
about secure the border
build up the economy you know the more
traditional issues that we've heard
about
well based on his rhetoric so far he
does he does invoke
culture war themes and narratives quite
a lot
which obviously does resonate with with
his base
and i think this is definitely one
that's on the forefront of a lot of
people's minds especially
as it relates to things like free speech
and obviously he he made in his
uh july 4 speech the fact that like it's
un-american
to not tolerate other viewpoints so i
think that very much does resonate with
people
the thing that's interesting as well is
that the trump administration has been
painted
by the left-wing and liberal mainstream
media
as being very anti-trans but actually
it's exactly what you just said michael
they are simply
rolling back all of these things that
obama did when
normally by covert means which where he
didn't actually have permission to do it
so for example the obama administration
issued
2016 guidelines about um
what to do with schools and colleges
with regard to bathrooms
and all that the trump administration
education department and department
justin said
was clarified that he can't do that that
has to go through
congress that has to go through the
normal channels of power but it has been
painted as this aggressively
anti-trans uh administration
which is it doesn't really uh hold to
the facts
of course because you have this
aggressive
attack on history from the left so
you kind of forget everything that
happened more than five minutes ago
when we hear an issue such as for
instance transgender people you know
men who think they're women serving in
the military
nobody supported that until about what
2015 i think it was
and so now if you reverse that decision
from the late obama administration
you're told that you're a tyrant a
monster
but this was the view that was held by
everybody including barack obama
including the most ardent leftists
until just five minutes ago do you think
looking
at this presidential election you've got
a guy joe biden who's been in politics
since 1776 actually he didn't sign the
declaration of independence but
he definitely was there at the time joe
biden has held
much more moderate views on on political
issues
until very recently is that going to
come back and bite him or does it not
matter is it all just about this present
moment
history and philosophy be damned
well it depends entirely on like the the
demographic you're talking about whether
it matters not because i think
the people who are vote a lot of people
who are voting for byron are voting
against trump
you know that this comes out in voting
voting enthusiasm
polls all the time it's very much they
are voting against trump so
so long as biden does not overnight turn
into trump yeah then
i think that this symbol of evil that is
president trump
will just be reason enough to to endorse
this that
would baiden know what's really
interesting is he has given his support
to
things like the equality act and so on
so forth whereas he's been quite
hesitant hesitant to give his support to
black lives matter
knowing that that's divisive i think he
just he's a he's an older guy
who doesn't actually realize how insane
yeah
this this particular issue is i mean
very few people do until they really
look into the fine print and say
whoa whoa you you want to do what with
women's ref
shelters you want to do what with with
children can gender confused children
like
i think i think it's ignorance actually
it's it's a fair point
you know it sounds all nice the equality
act who could disagree with that and joe
biden has been an empty suit his entire
career he
licks his finger he puts it in the wind
and he tries to figure out which way
it's blowing
there is kind of an irony though that
we're we're canceling halle berry we're
not letting her play certain roles
everything's about
the most marginalized and oppressed
groups and the democrats nominate
the oldest whitest guy in america i mean
president trump at least has a bit of
that orange sheen
so perhaps he could claim some kind of
minority status
but that's the way it goes and i guess
the way that uh that
joe biden can make sense of that is he
can just identify as somebody else i
think i think a lot of democrats
wish their nominee would identify as
somebody else uh maddie we've got to go
thank you as always for being here our
de facto co-host
here when i fill in on the bench bureau
show go read matty's stuff
over at national review follow her on
twitter
just just read all her stuff she's so
great maddie thank you as always
thanks for having me
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software
for contractors and small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description